Well, I have some very
urgent news to report.
You guys ready?
Yeah.
You got your urgent news hats on
because this is big stuff?
This must be so important.
It must be important.
Sounds serious.
Yeah.
Last week, I was in the Larchmont area
of Los Angeles with our producing deity.
The God, he's the man behind the scenes
who pulls the strings, Mr. Adam Sachs.
We were at this meeting in a building
and it was a, listen, this
is going somewhere important.
I'm sorry.
We were in this meeting,
building. (laughs)
Meeting in a in a building in Larchmont.
And of course everyone's
socially distancing.
There's not that many people there.
We've got our masks on.
It's all very safe.
And then we realized there's a balcony.
So we go out on the balcony
just to be able to breathe some air.
And it's Adam Sachs and I on the balcony
and we're on the third floor,
not that high up on a balcony.
And I looked down and
there's a young couple.
I want to say a man and a woman.
I'm going to say in their late
twenties, maybe 25, 28, 29.
And they've been standing there
and they're just looking up
and I walk out on the balcony
and just as they see me, the guys says,
"Kedakai, as God made her!"
Oh this makes me so happy.
And I was on top of this
balcony, like Mussolini.
And I was like, "Yes!"
And they were like, "Yay."
And then I went, "Kedakai!"
And they said, "Kedakai!"
And I'm like, I don't know,
it's nothing expresses
the power of a podcast
more than that insane moment.
I mean, we're in,
this country has so many problems,
so many things to deal with (laughs)
And you can use this for good.
And instead you use it
so people yell this thing at you.
I could be distributing
valuable information
on how you can go to certain websites
to get the vaccine where you can go,
how many times you should wash your hands.
There's all kinds of
good I could be doing,
instead I've spread this
foolishness across where
once the Dean of the actors studio,
Mr. James Lipton, I was
at a dinner with him
and he pointed up to a painting
of his wife in the nude
And wrote "Kedakai, as God made her!"
(laughs)
And I've said that and
I'm obsessed with it.
And then I sort of challenged people
and I've had people since come up to me
and yell it at me, once at the
Largo Theater through a gate.
And they yell it as if they've come up
with the secret word
that will save the earth.
That's how they say it.
And this, these people were, I think
had seen me go into the building.
And I think they waited.
Oh, that's good.
I think they waited, and they were like
he might come out at some point
and we've been told we have to do this.
That's dedication.
I applaud them.
I don't know who you, people are.
You were in the Larchmont
area, but God bless you.
You filled my head with delusions
(laughs)
and you're keeping me
going for another year.